this is the seventh round of
negotiations between iran and
signatories of the 2015 nuclear deal as
well as the united states
and one of the main sticking points for
the europeans had been iran's compliance
with the international atomic energy
agency until now
last night we reached a good agreement
with the iaea that could address some of
the alleged concerns about iran's
peaceful nuclear program and lead to
continued mutual cooperation with the
iaea
two series of texts are being discussed
in vienna the first is the result of six
rounds of talks at the same time other
parties have agreed to have iran's newly
proposed texts on the table so as to
achieve a single concise text from
discussions and combination of all of
these
iran says the iea will not be able to
allow to have cameras at one of its
sensitive sites
the director general of the un nuclear
watchdog has had some serious concerns
about the lack of access to what was
taking place at a workshop just outside
tehran where centrifuges are being made
but in june one of the cameras was
attacked and damaged
iranian officials accused israel of
sabotage
then iranian officials took all four
iaea cameras offline and refused to
allow inspectors to replace them now
with this technical agreement with the
iaea there is hope that the talks here
in vienna will get the push they need to
move forward in a practical sense it
means that the iaea again
will be able to monitor the production
of centrifuge components
this is what the garage facility does
and the reason for doing this is for the
iaea to have a better handle
on whether any centrifuge components
might be taken away from karaj
to be assembled into centrifuges at some
secret site
the remaining signatories of the nuclear
deal have been meeting since april to
try and get the u.s and iran to return
to the agreement which was aimed at
limiting iran's nuclear program in
exchange for economic benefits and
sanctions relief while the u.s is not
directly talking to iranian officials
here in vienna there seems to be renewed
optimism about the seventh round of
talks and now that the main issue
between iran and the iaea seems to be
resolved it will be up to the americans
to put forth what they're willing to do
to convince iran to return to full
compliance
dorsojabari al jazeera vienna